So we saw that a conservative
force is path independent.
And we also had
examples of forces
which are path dependent, if
you have a path 2 and path 1.
And the work done
is path dependent.
So that means for each path we
will get a different answer.
Then we call this force
F, be denoted by nc,
is called nonconservative.
And again, we see that
friction is the best example
of a nonconservative force.
And if we go again for
a nonconservative work,
if we integrate from
the initial point
to the final point, for
instance, on our path
1 of this nonconservative force,
so if we integrate this way
and if we reverse the
interval, and so we go back
from the final point to the
initial point on path 2,
that these integrals will not
be equal to the negative view
of each other because
the quantities are
different for the different
paths, in general,
and so this is nonzero.
And in fact, that's the property
of nonconservative forces,
that the work done
around a closed
path for a nonconservative
force is not equal to zero,
in general.
There may be one
specific closed path
in which that answer is zero.
But in general, it's nonzero.